are you a hedgehog or a fox
are you able to deeply focus on one
specific activity
such as rolling up in a spiky ball and
sleeping through the winter
or are you alert to changing
circumstances
and keep your eyes and ears open to new
threats and opportunities
my name's david spiegelhalter and i'm a
statistician and fascinated
by the problems of risk and prediction
philosopher isaiah berlin wrote a famous
essay the hedgehog
and the fox after a famous poem
by the greek poet archilicus who said
the fox knows many things but the
hedgehog
knows one big thing think of the people
you know
either privately or public figures
are they hedgehogs with one overarching
way of looking at the world
through which they interpret all around
them or are they foxes
with no big principles of philosophy who
muddle along
adapting to what turns up and changing
their minds along the way
politicians of course tend to be
hedgehogs
but some are more pragmatic and foxy
than others
now who would you trust most to make
predictions about the future
a confident hedgehog or an uncertain and
vacillating
fox this was put to the test in a long
series of experiments
by political scientist philip tetlock
who studied 284 experts
making 28 000 predictions about
long-term events tetlock was looking at
who predicted best
and mainly it made no difference whether
the forecaster was an optimist or a
pessimist
conservative or liberal the only
consistent pattern
was how they thought not what they
thought
he found that foxes were much better at
predicting
them were hedgehogs and hedgehogs were
particularly poor
at subjects of which they were experts
they were just
too confident in their forecasts
a classic hedgehog was the historian
arnold toynbee who in 1947 was declared
time magazine's man of the year others
wrote
that he was the most renowned scholar in
the world
or a universal sage largely because his
great work
a study of history spoke to the biggest
fear of the time
that nuclear weapons were going to end
civilization
toybe made the confident and comforting
prediction that this wouldn't happen
because it was in opposition to his
self-proclaimed
scientific theory of history toynbee
thought that western civilization wasn't
nearly done yet
because it hadn't reached the stage of
universal government
and a religious renaissance all 23
civilizations he had studied
had done so before they collapsed and so
would the west
he thought the golden age of universal
government
and religious observance would start
around the year 2000
his peers were skeptical and they were
right
today toybe is hardly remembered except
perhaps
as a classic hedgehog in his book future
babble
dan gardner identifies three
characteristics
of good forecasters number one
aggregation
they use multiple sources of information
are open to new knowledge
and are happy to work in teams number
two
metacognition they have an insight into
how they think
and the biases they might have such as
seeking evidence
that simply confirms preset ideas number
three
humility they have a willingness to
acknowledge
uncertainty admit errors and change
their minds
rather than saying categorically what is
going to happen
they are only prepared to give
probabilities for future events
acknowledging in the words of that great
sage donald rumsfeld
both the known unknowns and the unknown
unknowns
so when someone is telling you what is
in store for you
the country the world just ask yourself
are they a hedgehog or a fox
you